[Music]
thank you
my entire life I feel like I've been
living for others I'm pretty successful
but I feel like I don't care about the
success that I have
I don't really have the urge to live
anymore but I'm religious so I don't
have to capabilities of killing myself
sometimes I just wish I would just get
hit by a car as I'm walking home one day
just so I don't have to deal with living
anymore
all right when I was like
four maybe five years old remember
there's one time my mom asked me to get
her a cup of a cup of water so I go in
the bathroom and I don't know why I
decide to do this but I decided to get
the water
from the toilet instead because I wanted
to know if my mom would drink it or not
so gave him on the water it's out there
and I watched her down the whole cup
and I never regretted it and my mom
never knew about this I'm not going to
tell her ever that's it
[Music]
hi my name is
[Music]
Griffith today is
um every time I wear a thong I get a
rash between my butt cheeks I get like
immense Pleasures crashing it just
because it's a rash and like the pain
relieves or something and I make a face
and my boyfriend asked me are you
itching your butt every time and I say
no and I refuse to admit to him that I
scratch my butt and it gives me pleasure
foreign
is that I write about weed for a living
but my middle eastern father thinks I
write about herbal tea
[Music]
one time when I was little
I just be in my pants to enjoy the
experience because I was wondering
what is the experience to be in
Europeans you know and I never did that
so I start to pee in a school the
experience it was weird but at the same
time
it was fun you know this is the
embarrassed part because
I was very curious about it
[Music]
my my faceless secret is that my
roommate who's very nice and just moved
in made a lot of soup for and she texted
our group chat and she said I made a lot
of extra soup you guys can have some if
you want and I thought that was very
generous offer I said thank you and what
I've been doing is getting home late at
night and being very hungry and this is
embarrassing for so many reasons but
I've been just instead of taking the
soup out of her Tupperware and putting
it in a bowl like would be responsible
and
um like she's already giving something
and I'm actually I've just been eating
out of the Tupperware of soup with my
mouth and then putting the spoon back in
which feels like
like a rejection in some way like I am
spitting literally in the face of her
generosity but I don't know why it's
become a habit this happened a few times
now and
and yeah in fact this has been weighing
on me which is why I knew it so
immediately I'm gonna not do it again I
hope
that's it uh I would just say I hope
that I tell you in person if you ever
before you ever see this but thank you
for the soup and I'm sorry for my spin
net I don't know what's up a lot of
people think I'd be in fights and stuff
because I'm like big and I'm like tall
and a black woman but I do not be
advised I just talk a lot of [ __ ] and no
I can't back it up
okay we're right here on this picnic
blanket because we're celebrating my
birthday and there was an older man that
came and um hung out with us for a while
and that was my sugar daddy
I have genital herpes and I'm afraid
that no one will ever love me
uh I broke up with my girlfriend the
other day and I
feel less bad about it than I should but
it's very conflicting because I feel
both bad and good and I don't know if
I've dealt with that kind of Duality
before
I don't think I have a real personality
because I changed it so much for people
to like me
[Music]
I got my heart broken yesterday
[Music]
My secret is
[Music]
I think my ex-best friend is dead and it
might be my fault
[Music]
sometimes I get really jealous of my
friend's successes and it makes me feel
inferior and I really want to be
supportive but I
can't always be
[Music]
okay
um My secret is something I did that was
really bad
which was when I was in high school I
had a friend and she asked me if she
should get this haircut that I thought
was really ugly and I told her she
should do it and then she got the
haircut and it looked bad
that's my secret
[Music]
My secret is that I miss my best friend
even though she flipped me over
and was awful to be in the end of our
friendship
um I miss her and
I hope she's doing okay
[Music]
I think I fell in love with a friend
back in my hometown and I didn't know it
and I didn't do anything about it and uh
now I'm just confused because some
dating somebody else
uh
I don't know how to feel about anybody
hey
I know it's a channel that people share
secret here
what I'm gonna share is not that
uncommon
but I think it's a taboo in a lot of
different cultures
um yesterday and today is a festival in
my culture in Chinese culture it's meet
Autumn Festival
which people usually get together with
their family and celebrate
but
I hate those hat festivals I hate people
ask me
how I am doing with my family I hate
people ask me whether I enjoy the
holiday with my family I hate pretending
that I enjoyed it
the secret is
a lot of time
I did enjoy it
it was hard
to be with it and pretend that it's a
completion of family
now I'm like super far away from my
family I don't mind spending the whole
day alone
um in a way it's better than being with
them
but it is just super hard to admit
to friends co-workers or corners but I
believe a lot of people share similar
feelings like me
and
um I I don't think I'm alone
but it's just hard to admit that
that's it thank you
hi everyone
um I have an exciting announcement I'm
working on a book of secrets so if you
have a secret that you would be okay
with me including in the book please
submit it by going to the link in my
description or by going to thrive.com
and hitting the leave a secret tab I
have it set up to where you will be
submitting the secret completely
anonymously please only share a secret
if you are 100 okay with me sharing it
in the book and all my other platforms
don't share anyone else's Secrets only
share your own keep it Anonymous by not
including any names or by changing up
names don't share anything incriminating
and if you're under 18 please make sure
you get your parents permission I'm
hoping you'll be able to pre-order the
book by mid-november and that I'll have
them shipped out in time for the
holidays so keep an eye out for that
I'll let you guys know once it's ready
either on here or on one of my other
platforms and
um that's about it thank you guys for
everything I love you all and I'll see
you next
[Music]